Stewart is this you see us on the screen
it's just going to be the center camera
all right welcome to a special
of the impossible podcast with
Scholars that I have had on the podcast
both multiple times now and green
professor and colleague here at UC San
Diego
and my friend long time must pop
like
the portal podcast and and of course
Professor who recently had a very very
popular episode said that we called
physics is fine and it was based on a
Twitter thread storm that came out at
the end of December in which Dan
highlighted discoveries and physics that
had not been really rewarded with the
Accolade of the Nobel Prize yet uh
perhaps never but but at least as of the
moment had not been uh rewarded or with
that particular remuneration and there's
been a lot of controversy as I said
around the description of physics as
having stagnated most most forcefully or
vocally by Sabina hasenfelder also
eight-time guest on the podcast was just
just behind Eric's record set for this
particular event but I wanted to have
both a gentlemen here together to
discuss the future of physics is they
see it and what's right with physics
what we could do with physics or what we
could change or modify what opportunity
as there are and sort of moderate that
from the perspective of a simple
experimental cosmologist and my
perspective on things so we're going to
talk about
particle physics experiment Theory we're
going to talk about unification of
forces and Fields perhaps and we're
going to have it as I said a nice clean
fight we're going to go t-o-e to toe uh
I did it I made that joke you didn't
think I would so uh I think I'll start
with uh with Dan just to recapitulate
from our previous episode that aired
last week you can find it uh and the
channel archives called physics is fine
uh what was the what was the motivation
for that particular tweet storm
um yeah so thanks for having me on it's
nice nice to get a chance to talk to
both of you
um so the my the motivation behind the
thread was to articulate some of the
things that I've picked up on at being
an active researcher that I thought were
you know important events for me in
understanding how the world works and
making progress in clearly observational
topics like cosmology
um but also important theoretical ideas
um that that had a huge impact on how I
see the world that I didn't think were
always uh well understood or appreciated
by people like even other researchers
outside of their own Fields so it was
just to kind of communicate the value of
what had been happening and one of the
reasons for that is that you know as a
researcher it's really important to know
you know what are what am I aiming for
like what would be a result that would
really stand out amongst the best
results the past five years you know
we'd all like to be Einstein but just
for me I just you can't always you won't
always achieve those but maybe having
hierarchy of results in your mind is
really important for just gauging you
know where progress you know what counts
as progress what kind of progress is
going on
and Eric you've been interacting
even interacting and engaging with the
said tweet and also with our friend
Sabina and Martin Bauer who generously
provided a book called Nobel dreams
which is somewhere around here
um what was your reaction to this you
had sort of a a provocative comment that
we shouldn't we should just get past the
point that yes there's been a lot of
progress in condensed matter physics and
theoretical astrophysics experimental
cosmology what what are you most
interested in in doing to move the
conversation forward from your
perspective
thanks for asking so I'd like to do this
in the
of the clickbaity kind of thumbnail
sketches I was outraged Dan frankly by
this tweet store sorry it's gonna get a
little fantastic uh I'm bored by all the
opening moves uh we have a suite of
moves where somebody says there's a
crisis in fundamental physics and then
somebody mishears it and says you have
no idea what's going on in Material
Science it's never been a more exciting
time you say that's not what I said well
who's to say what's fundamental is
cosmology fundamental so this is the
sort of weird dance that people get into
at the beginning and I've said I'd
rather just say Roy Lopez spaski
variation and get to the middle middle
game rather than wasting time on the
intro so I think it would be appropriate
given that I'm not a physicist to seed a
bunch of things
first of all being that I'm not a
physicist I think that the issue is not
about physics in the large it's really
about the sort of core Central issue
which people are very squeamish about
now because nobody wants to say that any
field is any more important than any
other which is ridiculous
there is a central core of fundamental
physics which is the thing that
scratches the itch we have when we're
not physicists and we want to know what
is the universe who am I where why am I
here how does the world work what is
this place made of
and those questions have stagnated and
I'm sort of somewhat arbitrarily but not
that arbitrarily tying that to February
1st of 1973 with the publication of the
Kobayashi mascara paper enlarging the
kabibo angle to three generations
and I believe there are eight particle
theorists left on Earth who have won a
Nobel Prize now that also causes a
certain variation in the opening because
somebody will say well you seem to be
very hung up on the Nobel Prize it's
like no than me
but
the fact is is that the Nobel Prize is a
somewhat conservative measure of
progress
and as a conservative measure of
progress when you're down to your last
eight people who have proven that they
are physicists by being able to make
contact with reality at that level
50 years is a long time I think the
longest recent drought of this kind was
between 1928 and 47 with the Advent of
QED by duroc as the first real Quantum
field Theory before the sort of
primitive renormalization program came
in and cleared up the ability to compute
so I absolutely celebrate Dan's tweet
storm I think that it had lots of great
papers many of which I knew nothing
about so I educated myself and I got a
chance to look at Dan's work a bit but
that said one of the things I think that
tweetstorm did and I think Dan
acknowledged it as much is that it
didn't clearly State the
um
the results that would constitute
unambiguous change in fundamental
physics that is what is what is the
field content of the world what stuff is
it that's running around are there new
things that we haven't figured out
um what constitutes the new interactions
of the stuff that we have and the stuff
that may come to be and the other issue
of unification
would be space spaces so we currently
have something called space time and
it's not clear whether there is a
problem with space-time itself so I
would say that Dan did a great service
talking about all the sorts of things
that are not in crisis and I wish to
seed instantly that it is not that
physics is in crisis which is the thing
that everybody can understand easily but
it is the core Central issue of what
physics can be is meant to be that
excites our imaginations and our
passions answers philosophical questions
that is in a prolonged state of and I
would say unnecessary self-inflicted
crisis well just
get the opportunity to address that so I
recently you feel that this essay by
David Foster Wallace called This is
water it's got you're drinking some
vodka so hopefully you're familiar with
it uh so it's a parable of these these
two fish that are young fish and they're
they're in the ocean they're swimming
around and um all of a sudden an older
fish comes by and says hey boys how's
the water and he goes on his way
and then the two fish look at each other
once that's the other one what the hell
is water
uh is that possible let me not stand for
are we obsessed with space-time are we
in space-time in the same way that these
fish are in water and are we so are we
rightfully
um to be maybe ashamed or view it as
something to be dispensed with
altogether as I think Einstein or Lorenz
or both of them or neither of them are
nemas have claimed what is space time
why is that why is that sort of the the
Pinnacle and how can you see that
getting under Eric's skin
um yeah I mean for sure that's the one
of the great questions of science uh so
in we think that space time probably
emerges from something in a lot of
examples we've studied life String
Theory where you know our ultimate hope
for resolution of the singularity the
beginning of you know beginning of time
is probably something non-geometric
there's if we understand what's going on
there it will not be in terms of
geometry at least of the kind of
space-time uh we experience
um I think the thing I would say is in
response to you are we unnecessarily
obsessed with it I do think that that
there are questions of this nature like
you know what was what happened before
the Big Bang and some of those questions
we don't have the tools to answer we
don't have data to help guide us and
even if someone writes down a theory
that works like we may have no way to
test it someone can come up with another
theory and so there is a lot of like
we're not guaranteed that we're going to
be able to answer all the questions that
you know are deeply held questions of
you know Humanity going back at eons but
I do think that like so there are
aspects of these questions we I don't
think we're guaranteed that we can make
progress on all the questions we'd like
to
um and you know what is happens at space
time when it cease to be you know the
kind of thing we experience on our scale
does it continue to exist down to these
these scales you know we'd love to be
able to answer that question but I also
don't think we
necessarily our promise that we'll ever
have answers or at least in hundreds of
years time scale
um and so I don't see that as The
Benchmark at which all decisions of
progress have to have to be made
you know you know I guess when I hear
that I check it against things that I
believe so one when you say geometric
it's not that it will be non-geometric
it's that it won't be the specific
geometry and you sort of corrected that
mid-flight so if if uh if Albert
Einstein told us to embrace Embrace
semi-ramanian geometry it's not simply
going to be a semi-ramanian manifold
which is basically four degrees of
freedom together with uh one set of
rulers and uh four rulers for each
degree of freedom and six protractors
between them so you have 10 variables
that get chosen by an equation and then
that thing to the extent that I
understand your quite your your point
it's that there are these singularities
one is at the beginning of time if you
will in the standard Friedman Robertson
Walker model and the other one is at the
base of a black hole which is The
schwarze Shield Singularity and one
modern interpretation is that the
singularities result from crime sins
that we don't even know we've committed
and so we're trying to figure out what
to do as Penance so as to remove these
singularities but if I listen to what
you're saying very carefully
I see something which I'm very alarmed
by which is the you're not suspicious
either one of you enough of the language
before
speaks to one dimension of time and only
R1
has an ordering in the absence of other
structure our two or three or four don't
have such a thing so when there is an
arrow of time it makes good sense
ordinary to say nothing of cardinaling
um to speak of before but if the
ultimate structure uh as I believe has
multiple dimensions of time you will
find that the crutch of saying initial
conditions has to be replaced by
something like boundary conditions
and in such a situation one of the
things that's really interesting to me
is that we have the lagrangians the
equations the field content which is the
science but we also have this way of
talking around it and the way in which
we have of talking around it carries a
tremendous amount of weight and a lot of
that I think is grooving each generation
to fail as its successors failed because
what we're doing is we're putting a
tremendous amount of pressure saying if
you don't learn to speak the way you we
do you will not be able to survive to
adulthood to have your own thesis
students and therefore you had better
learn to talk as we do and I think that
that's one of the things that I'm very
concerned about I don't believe in that
before is as simple as we're making out
so I I guess I would I would push back
on that I mean I don't think it's I mean
we can use it's helpful to use everyday
language and then add okay it could be
different right like it's helpful to
start from the things we know are true
and we can ask questions like could
there be extra dimensions of time or you
know even just the evolution from is do
we know that quantum mechanics is the
only possible way that the world could
work there are lots of people and and I
include myself in them that are
interested in pushing the boundaries but
it start it also helps to start from a
place of what we know like I think there
are plenty of people who throw away
literally all the physics and they go
well I don't want to be constrained by
the structures of physics and it really
hurts their careers because they can't
they don't even understand basic physics
which stops them from being able to make
meaningful progress because if you can't
if you can't explain what we already
understand you can't extend the
structure in new and interesting ways so
with the example of multiple time
directions like people do consider this
like in you know you know well-respected
theoretical physics groups for many
different motivations either purely just
as a tool to understand physics but in
other cases really because they're
interested in like what would it mean
and what are the implications but since
we don't like
all of our life experience is still
rooted in one time like I think it's
still reasonable to say
for sure you have to recover that but at
the same time I don't think like I think
it's good to establish that like we have
a language that works well for
describing a lot of the universe and
that we talk about how we break that
those those things in controlled ways so
generalizations of say like number of
time Dimensions or say changes to the
rules even so we're not even doing
quantum mechanics like those things are
really interesting directions but
they're very constrained because most of
them don't even describe daily life in
any meaningful way like most mutations
in biology lead to things getting far
worse rather than better it's a rare
mutation that works but what you've said
is not actually true in science it's
often the case that people make huge
breakthroughs because they don't
understand the errors of a previous
generation so for example you know you
had the Stray hydrogen atom on the
nucleotides that was in all the books in
the wrong place and it happened that
Watson and Crick were in an office with
Jerry Donahue who said you know all the
books are wrong and if you look in the
double helix it's about you know a page
and a half or something before Jim
Watson figures out the hydrogen bonds
that explain the chargraph
equimollar relations and you have
similar things if you were you know in
the 1940s trying to study
electromagnetism and its effect on
electric electrons you would almost
certainly think that was the electric
and magnetic fields that impacted an
electron being passed around the
solenoid and surprisingly enough in the
50s we learned that there were classical
consequences of electromagnetism that we
had really wrong because we put all of
our weight if you will on the E and B
fields of electromagnetism and not on
the electromagnetic four potential which
in fact is something which is not a
convenience product meant to recover
classical electromagnetism it in fact
has weight as was shown by Bowman
aaronov
I mean I I don't disagree with that
point of view I would just say that
the there's not a I don't think there's
a lack of contrarianism in the field and
I don't think that that
I don't think there's people feel
they're unable to take take risks I
think the problem is that like there's
no con if you don't understand the
starting point it's very difficult to
take risks that are in a productive way
right so if I don't understand why we
think the world how the world Works in
this room it's very difficult to think
well what are the limitations of how I
break the structures that I understand
so I would say you know people
understanding you know the
you know trying to propose you know
generalizations in all kinds of
directions almost all of them are doomed
to fail from the start and I think many
people were like well that's you know
people trying to put unnecessary
constraints on me I'm a free thinker
it's like no that's not people trying to
believe that's reality putting
constraints on you and I think that's we
have to separate there's definitely
sociological challenges for young people
to do really creative things but there's
also just reality that plants that's a
real challenge to being super creative
because I don't I just have a completely
different impression of your field from
outside which is people come to me and
they say I can't afford to work on what
I really want to work on I don't believe
many of the things that I'm being fed
with my mother's milk
um I can understand them but every time
I deviate more than a certain amount or
in a way that is not thought well of by
the community all conversations die off
and I'm cautioned that this is an
extremely Brave thing to do in the sense
that bravery is stupidity and I think
that what you're saying is a hope and a
wish which in a few cases I don't want
to say that it's a hundred percent
across the board but I do believe that
in part
um we don't have this freedom in this
field and we don't have the freedom to
continue to get engagement from the
community because in general we get
these mega programs that are cropping up
and in the mega programs there are all
sorts of assumptions that have been
layered
on which are not proven and you know I
would love to apply this rule to some of
the major mega programs and say hey
you're in the wrong number of Dimensions
you've got the wrong signature you've
got the wrong symmetries you've got the
wrong field content
and you know it becomes this thing where
the person then says oh no no it's a toy
Theory you know I I'm in a small
euclidean number of Dimensions with su2
as the symmetries of the universe and
I'm I'm super symmetric I'm doing all of
this stuff
which is not the physical world that we
live in so far as we understand it and
the idea is that that person is saying I
wish to suspend the normal rules of
science because I'm doing toy stuff in
order to learn about the structures that
are going to elucidate the actual one
physical universe that we're in now when
you do that I understand that but what
we're talking about is something like
scientific immunity and if you've ever
met somebody with diplomatic immunity
some of them have the feeling that they
can park wherever they want to and they
don't have to pay fines and that they're
not subject to the laws of the land that
they inhabit and what I'm trying to say
is you cannot have these mega programs
uh
casually imposing the strictest
expectations on its competitors and then
giving itself a permanent free pass to
go on for decades and decades about
nothing
oh just uh push back with loving respect
uh so that's two actual physicists
against one non-physicist I like my eyes
I know but you you you're an honorary
physicist I'm sorry I'm sorry to tell
you you're an honorary physicist uh so
you know you're taking basically the
opposite point if I'm wrong correct me
but of of this guy up here not Weinstein
but Einstein you know who never thought
any of his predictions would be
verifiable and yet they proved to be
very very useful approximations toy
models uh let's look at Schwartz child I
mean we already mentioned the sports
child Singularity uh that was thought to
be you know completely impractical uh
never detectable Einstein subsequently
also disavowed the uh the detectability
of gravitational waves gravitational
lensing and yet it was remarkably
prescient in that the toy model Works in
you know basically 99.99 of all
situations where we could ever hope to
apply it so toy models are extremely
powerful and just to add on to that
um you and I were talking before we Dan
came in about you know string theory in
that very realm
um you know sometimes it is useful to
take a and again I'm speaking as a
simple experimental cosmologist not a
theorist but to take a toy model or take
something that we know uh Works in
certain situations like the Klein Gordon
equation uh which it doesn't apply
unless I'm wrong to any real particles
but it is useful to apply in a way of
generating other Solutions does with
with modifications with with an
idealized modifications that's perfect
my point it's a toy model so what's
wrong with toy models we we get a lot of
violence nothing is wrong with toy model
you're saying that you're being excluded
or maybe not part of the physics program
unless you engage in something that I
don't think that's this is just
uncomfortable because it's like let me
Begin by saying String Theory can't hurt
anyone
right string theory is a set of ideas
it's a constellation of hypotheses and
it's a place to play there's nothing
wrong with string theory nor Loop
quantum gravity the problem is with and
I don't want to put it all on strength
there is it's the problem is quantum
gravity sociology which has blown a
physics-shaped hole
uh in fundamental physics and replaced
it
with a set of double standards in which
I want to know what are the rules if the
rules are we all get to play then hot
hot diggity dog let's all play and if
the rules are
we should be very careful that things
agree with experiments and any attempt
to talk about something as uh that is
violated you know like as soon as dorak
finds that a times B is not equal to B
times a when he tries to take the square
root of your your client equation
um you know it's a it's a short period
of time before he says well maybe A and
B aren't numbers the matrices and then
it's like okay so you did something that
was wrong that didn't make any sense and
then it did make sense later the problem
that I have is that we have one set of
players that is functioning in some
sense as both the referees and a team so
imagine that you're playing in the NFL
and you've got the Foot Locker sends a
team so all their employees are dressed
in vertical black and white stripes and
they take the field they're not
particularly talented but the one thing
that they have to be worse than on
Sunday Super Bowl final call
what they do is that they start saying
you know offsides
you're like what why do you guys get to
do this you're not you're playing on the
field you're not in a position to do
that the problem is the cancerous
sociology of quantum field Theory
because this field is given excuses that
the rest are not and it imposes the most
strict attempts to impose like
scientific falsifiability and to tell
people that you're out you're out you're
out well 70 years later after Bryce
DeWitt enters an anti-gravity
competition with his famous essay we're
still wrestling with a product that
doesn't ship which is imposing standards
on other fields and it's really
important to blow that up in our
lifetime so that we can all move forward
together so I actually celebrate what
you're saying about toy models I just
want to make sure that we don't have
scientific immunity for quantum gravity
well I just want to point out that Bryce
Dewitt's book on anti-gravity is so
engaging that you just can't put it down
uh Dan I want to ask you is this a is
are we having a discussion about
sociology or are we going to talk about
the actual ideas Behind these these
these issues because when you and I
spoke I said when you guys get to I
don't know what you guys do over there
in theory but but the bottom line is
someone's got to keep an eye on you
um you know I know we don't we don't
pick a person we don't pick a field when
we want to hire a young Professor we
want to hire you I was part you know the
milieu I didn't actually I wasn't on the
committee but it was part of that meal
yeah so I didn't say oh I really want
someone who you know has worked on on
strict Theory cause no it's it's a sort
of a target of opportunity in some cases
we were stealing you away from another
University but but the point is is the
sociology inside the the host organism
or is it something that is perceived as
as being afflicting it from outside from
an outside so I I'm going to agree with
Eric in some ways and disagree in others
but let me let me let me um let's start
with this do you agree I'll start where
we agree which is like so the the
problem when you feel gets too big is
that it doesn't have to refer outside
right and that's I think what you're
getting at which is like we make our own
rules we play by our own rules and I
never have to make contact with not just
with nature but the rest of the world
right I'm big enough and and you know we
can go to conferences with a thousand
people and never talk to anyone who's
spoken a different language or thought
about another problem so I think I I'm
saying that because what I really see is
makes the difference most of the time
between the the areas where the toy
model makes progress or the people
working on the toy model really are
meaningfully moving the field forward is
their ability to to both what they're
working on connects to other fields but
they're they're also able to understand
what other fields need from them and how
their toy models are addressing that
right so so for someone working on let's
say Quantum field three in two
Dimensions like you could do it and it
you could do it in such a way that's
like why are these people wasting all
their time but then there are other
people that go that were working on
Quantum field 3 in two Dimensions were
like condensed matter physicists and
they were like you know no we're working
on this because these are solvable
models of phase transitions material and
and it's the ability to communicate
outside of your area that's really
important for the health of the the
health field and to keep those toy
models
coming in contact with nature right if
you're not interacting with the people
for whom your toy model is supposed to
be making contact then it really is
useless right if you're not I mean maybe
it'll be useful eventually someone 100
years later useless but well but but I
do think it's valuable to both parties
the people who are more in touch with
nature and the people who are just
trying to make progress to communicate
with each other in a productive way and
where where I'll agree with you is that
and I'm not just going to say String
Theory I think many fields reach a point
that they're so self-sustaining that
nobody in that field feels the need to
talk outside I'm happy not to say String
Theory once for the rest of this I want
to talk about quantum gravity is the
problem but which subsumes string theory
and it doesn't point the finger at
string theory in particular yeah but I I
would say like again and that doesn't I
would not even I would say it's true
even in areas that are experimentally
driven like this phenomena of a field
becoming big enough that it does not
have to refer to Nature or progress or
anything and it just as long as we're
making everyone in our community happy
and we're still speaking the same
language then we're all doing that are
you a miserating other communities am I
uh um no no in these large programs
I'm even somewhat understanding if you
guys want to take some portion of the
resources and go off into a cloistered
Monastery and talk to each other for 40
years as long as it's not too much
that's fine it's when you start telling
other people that they're stupid
and when you test to say that I don't
know why anyone else works on anything
else that's dumb and then you start
talking about the fact that uh you play
up all of your competitor Fields
problems you don't
own your own what you're talking about
is sort of a scientific pathology and
our uncomfort or discomfort in dealing
with this phenomenon causes us to do
proxy arguments one proxy argument is
quantum gravity the problem with it is
it doesn't make contact with experiment
come on right or it doesn't fit the
scientific method oh you're going to
repeat the big bang and just so you have
large n give me a break right another
one is beauty Sabine is very you know
focused on beauty well she's she's doing
that in a way to avoid the head-on
collision with what she's really trying
to say I'm not trying to avoid the
head-on collision what I'm trying to say
is we cannot afford for an imperial
culture
to be telling other cultures that are
trying to work on the same problems that
they cannot exist because you've got
everything wrapped up and and literally
we have a situation in which
um your you know your colleague uh David
E Kaplan was recently featured in an
interview where he just let loose and I
I know David who did the film Particle
Fever and what he was talking about was
the feeling that he was dumb and stupid
and couldn't get something we used to
have a game called tag war in my
neighborhood a new kid would come
we'd say let's play tag war and they
would try to figure out the rules of tag
war and more or less it was hazing and
abuse
and after about two and a half three
weeks where we changed the rules over
and over again so that it finally
personally I don't understand the rules
it feels like there are no rules that's
when they became part of the
neighborhood because it was it stood for
the game without any rules that was what
tag War meant and my feeling about this
is
um we have a tag War problem coming out
of quantum gravity that is stalling the
core field that has to get addressed in
the lifetime of the people who are still
there who created the problem because
good science requires that they go back
to their statements where there are a
lot of people who are no longer here
people who began their careers in the
1980s how old were you during the
anomaly cancellation 1984. uh two years
old there you go
you have no idea what it was like and
you can read about it but the fact of
the matter is it was an absolutely
brutal thing and you know Brian Green
and I have been having a back and forth
about this he got asked on Kurt
geimongal's program
about what are these issues that people
keep talking about he said oh well you
know we were very enthusiastic and I
heard you say this thing about you know
particle theorists are like bosons they
all line up in the sort of finding the
same things interesting no North Koreans
line up and find the same things
interesting Iraqis under Saddam Hussein
all voted the same way you have a
problem which is why they're behaving
like bosons rather than fermions and why
the fermions are being you know
evolutionary theory has a concept called
interference competition where if you
have one animal that tries to keep
another animal from being able to get to
the Salt Lick or the water or the food
and that other animal that's being kept
from that dies off and that's how we've
lost these people there are so many
theories and interesting people who are
no longer with us because of this mad
grab for resources quoting something
like White Man's Burden you know
manifest Destinies it is our manifest
destiny to change the problem we used to
have a concept called unified field
Theory or unification that went away and
it got supplanted by something called
quantum gravity and that became the
thing that got rolled out through Dennis
Overby and the New York Times repeated
in Science magazine
ad nauseam until everyone was
brainwashed thinking you know the
problem of our time is quantum gravity
and it's not
I mean are you saying we need you know
literal tribunals to get Edward Whitton
and uh and uh paulczynska well we can't
get polchinski anymore but uh what what
is it what's really bothering you I
understand that this is that these are
challenges these are it's frustrating to
have a field that's had from one
perspective the a lack of progress but
entrenched because of The Prestige of
the previous practitioners but again I
like to point this out yeah in 1859
there was a very bright guy by the name
of James Clerk Maxwell who worked very
hard and had a successful model of
electromagnetic wave propagation uh that
in the sense that a predicted
experimental observables but it was
based on whirlpools and Eddies and and
all sorts of other things to
substantiate an ether likes material for
it so he was right uh for the wrong
reasons or wrong for the right reason
Galileo same thing he thought the tides
were caused by the Earth's rotation
they're really caused by the moon so now
other words why is it so important that
we punish Edward I mean I would like to
be punished maybe Edward Whitton has
something to say about this behavior and
I would love to hear qumran and Brian
Greene and Lenny suskin uh as well as uh
you know Natty cyberg and Eva
Silverstein it would be great to have
these people in a dialogue you know
Natty cyborg said something he said
string theorists are very arrogant if
somebody comes up with something that
makes progress that isn't String Theory
we'll just say it's string theory
I'm like
no you there's a concept called mustn't
you don't get to do that stuff you're in
the wrong field if that's how you feel
and I I know Natty and we have a cordial
relationship
um
you don't get to play that way and you
don't get to call people stupid unless
you're gonna back it up or it can it can
come back at you I mean I would be happy
to talk to Lenny suskin and talk to him
about all the people he's insulted over
the years because he's all very open
about he's not hiding it and just say
you're an old man you're at the end of
your career how'd it go
what happened
did did you make the progress that your
friend Feynman made or Murray Gelman or
any of the people that you knew from a
previous era and my feeling about this
pardon me that's a very high standard
we're talk let's talk about you know the
A Team The Institute for advanced study
at some point recently had Robert
Digraph string theorist as its director
Natty cyberger string theorist
Edward Whitton
uh Juan malda Cena and then Nema was the
sort of off a little bit in
non-necessarily quantum gravity land
that's an enormous investment
in
in quantum gravity and the problem that
I'm having with this is you know Dan
Friedan a prominent quantum gravity
researcher talked about this openly said
science only works when we actually go
back and look at how we've behaved and
to confront our own failures this is the
same thing with the bootstrap method I
feel like what we're doing is we're
living the Jeffrey chew nightmare all
over again
do you feel like that's the challenge
that we're facing well I'd first like to
just like I think we can agree that
there can be sociology problems but I
would also say like as a young person
I find the same level of saying that
there's been no progress in physics you
know it's insulting to young people who
are not part of this who feel like we're
making real progress who see real
progress happening
but if but at the same time if you
you're going back to like a generate a
much General older generation and you're
saying and we're painting everyone who's
come back in the past 40 years as being
complicit with this and we can't think
for ourselves and we're being influenced
by it and it doesn't make it easier for
us to go off just to just say we're
we've made no progress doesn't help it
easier but that's that's a total
mischaracter is it I mean it's just I've
never said anything so simplistic in my
life what I've said is when you try to
say that you're going to quantize
gravity what you're talking about is
quantizing geometry and what happened
was the most romantic backfire possible
in The Sciences is that you instead
geometry is the Quantum and the great
legacy of these people is that they
figured out the quantum field Theory
really has nothing to do with physics
physics as we understand that the
physical world is one input to the
quantum field Theory machine Quantum
field theory is really about waves on
waves and that happens in keyboardism
theorem and algebraic topology
it happens in conformal theory that has
nothing to do with the physical
dimensions and Realms what we found out
was fascinating because in fact it
backfired and there's nobody who would
like to celebrate all the good that
Digraph and Natty and Ed and Company did
in this story including the celebration
of the toy models the problem that I'm
having is that they reordered the field
I mean if you this is a book that I keep
very close to me
um because it's a conference that
happened at the exact moment before the
anomaly cancellation
and Murray Gilman gave a keynote address
at Shelter Island 2 the conference That
was supposed to recapitulate the 1947
conference that got physics back on
track so they're trying to get back the
map
the magic he says as usual solving the
problems of one era has shown up the
critical questions of the next the very
first ones that come to mind looking at
the standard theory of today he's
talking about the standard model
uh why this particular structure for the
families in particular why flavor chiral
with left and right-handed particles
being treated differently why three
families that's a generalization of
Robbie's famous question
how many sets of Higgs bosons are there
in the standard Theory
and why su-3 cross su2 cross U1 why
those symmetries now in all of those
cases
those are classical questions and what
you see and the reason that it's
important that your generation know its
history is is that one of the things
that happens in marketing is that you
have a product and you have to create a
problem
so that your product fills that hole
right and this is what happens with the
76 Trombones in The Music Man right
you've got a problem and it's pool and
the solution is music
and okay what these people did to the
field was that they reordered our
concept of what our principal problems
were around the problems that they
thought they were most likely to solve
and I don't need them to be in pain I
don't want to see I'm not particularly
vindictive but what I do want to see is
tell me about all the people that uh
whose careers were terminated during
this tell me what they were working on
should we have them back shall we have
conferences devoted to what if quantum
gravity doesn't exist shall we actually
ask because what you talked about with
heterodoxy is that you're usually
talking about Orthodoxy plus Epsilon
you know I'm going to go out in a limb
and say sterile neutrinos well that's
not really very heterodox and then maybe
you go a little bit I'm going to say
they're multiple axions to solve the
strong CP problem plus you know create
Cosmic birefringe whatever these things
are
um they're not really what we're talking
about in terms of heterodoxy and it's
just it's very important to either
impose these rules on this group of
people or to relax the rules for other
people so that we can have truly
different ideas because I think that we
will probably find that over the last 50
years there were many ideas that will
fall into the final theory that were
pushed aside into the dust bin by this
group
I mean again I want to take it back to
what I think is is certainly not to
invalidate anything you've said Eric but
I think that that might be parochial to
the extent that it may involve certain
members of the community who aren't
affiliated with these three-letter
organizations like IAS or MIT or
whatever
NSA uh but but I think what's more
interesting and you know Dan is free to
apply in any way he likes and respond to
you but but the point you know I think
is is how many flowers should be
blooming right now I mean there are you
mentioned a couple of different you know
Alternatives of low quantum gravity and
other things uh at what point do you
would you have to say the portfolio
should be fully Diversified and then we
should actually devote you know equal uh
you know amounts of uh right but I know
but now you're saying well we should
have you know hold these people to
account well first of all I mean correct
me if I'm wrong but I don't think Edward
witton's published something on string
theory in a decade I mean the last thing
I saw is he wants us to go visit a black
hole to see if there's a one microsecond
time to lay at the end edge of you know
5au or something like that I don't know
what to what extent he's still holding
sway over the field uh that that you're
in Eva is actually much much younger
say yeah he was on the podcast two years
ago and I confronted him as all podcasts
are legal podcasters are legally
obligated to do and I said what about
this claim that there's been no uh you
know experimentally falsifiable things
predicted by by string theory he said oh
no no you're wrong and you can go back
and see this episode but didn't you ask
about like what he wanted on his
Tombstone oh what do you want on his
Tombstone yeah that and uh and Michio
Kaku uh very similar answers the
equations of string theory right so but
but let me let me just finish one thing
that he did say is well no it's not true
String Theory does predict the mass of
the electron shall be between 10 to the
minus 35 Planck masses and 10 to the
minus one Planck masses and yeah that
sounds all funny we can laugh about it
but you know and and you know
logarithmic space it's it's not it's not
terrible I I guess the point being to
what extent were something thing like
Loop quantum gravity which many people
including my friend Carlo ravelli has
been on the podcast many times uh he has
said that yeah there are challenges
there are experimental falsifications of
some of the claims of loop quantum
gravity in particular for for uh
propagation velocity versus
electromagnetic frequency of distant
quasars but but the point I guess I'm
trying to make is if you are the
director of the IIs you know you clean
house
is it really I mean what String Theory
have have you know just yes or no simply
would String Theory have a place in
there would chronic gravity have a place
in a geometric Unity have the the the
the that we need to worry about
permanent positions I think that the key
issue I mean let me let me just say some
things people won't associate with me in
general
string theorists
part of the quantum grab I have to use
string theory there because it's it's
they're smarter
and that's uncomfortable but they're
really really smart and they're really
really good at Quantum field there you
know and
I see that and I'm happy about that
what's more meant more really good at
geometry
and it's incredibly impressive and I
think that it does wonderful things for
the field to have progress going on in
the gym on the treadmill when you're not
actually running a marathon so in a
certain sense
in that particular sub-community the
people are in extremely good shape but
the generals have been playing war games
for 50 years because there were no
warnings to fight they have a distorted
sense of what being a general actually
is because they haven't seen action but
I would never want these people driven
out of the field I don't I don't know
anyone I praise as much as Edward
Whitton for his contributions
principally to geometry and to the
structure of quantum field Theory
although not the quantum field theory
that we seem to live within so I don't
think that that's really the argument
that I'm making and I think that part of
the problem is that this is a very click
bait thing about you know string theory
is BS versus no String Theory the power
and the Glorious strength there it's of
no interest to anyone what you said
about Loop quantum gravity though is
interesting I asked Lee smolen about
this it was a friend he says yeah the
original hope for Loop quantum gravity
is not realized without other ideas this
does not work it doesn't carry the day
and it doesn't behave as expected now
say what you want about Lee smullen and
I'll be honest a lot of people in that
other community in quantum gravity say
incredibly negative things about Lee
smaller but he behaved
properly there's no need for a tribunal
when a leader of the field says you know
what we were exuberant and they were
exuberant
we were optimistic they were optimistic
but they didn't go about with this
Manifest Destiny nonsense and they can
reflect and say you know what it doesn't
work the way we thought or we can't get
fermions into the theory comfortably or
something like that and I I really think
that we have to understand the different
but the ethics in blue quantum gravity
are much better than the ethics in its
competitor
well I think I mean I again I I I think
where I push back is just I think you're
often identifying understanding Quantum
field Theory with doing quantum gravity
research
um and I for me like I would say the
young people in the so you want the
older Veterans of the field to say they
were wrong and that may never happen no
no no maybe they're not I think if you
allow them to Facebook issue but I think
if you talk to the like I think the
response you're talking about which is
like do people see the challenges I
think what a lot of younger people would
say the lessons has been learned from
string theory is that we didn't
understand Quantum field Theory well
enough to be ready to jump like we've
learned so many lessons about just
Quantum field theory that we were kind
of out over our skis thinking oh we've
got this Quantum field Theory thing
we've solved we should be jumping to
quantum gravity and we've learned so
much about Quantum field Theory and
Quantum field theory is certainly
relevant to you know data and real life
and cosmology and it doesn't matter it
covers everything it's the you know and
to steal a headline from a from an
article on the certain Courier it's the
like the theory of theories right it
like organizes not just like one Theory
but sort of how all Theory theories fit
together what is the theory of theory so
so this was used as a title to an
article about effective field Theory but
it was just understand that a lot of
what we've been learning is you know
what is the space of theories that are
self-consistent like what what are the
rules and part of the you know why was
you know like one of the things we got
out of string theory what like the
string Community was adfc of T and what
that told us is a lot of things that we
had been thinking were people had been
thinking were problems that were going
to be solved by the string or really
phenomena that was that was living in
everyday Quantum field theory that we
hadn't fully understood and I would say
my generation probably more like a lot
of people who I think you might look at
and say you know based on their training
like who their PHD advisors were you
might say well that's a string theorist
and I would say I don't think they ever
do String Theory like they do Quantum
field Theory and because they feel very
relevant they've moved to that but I
think some never did it like literally
at no point in their graduate career at
any point they have a like so myself I
did String Theory when I was younger I
would not characterize myself as a
strength there's or someone who ever
uses String Theory I nobody told me I
had to do String Theory you have
characterized yourself as somebody who
finds it useful in what you do
absolutely you are using but because I
learned because of the the the
phrase what was useful is that string
theory was always characterized as you
know what is it what's the problem
quantum gravity we're trying to solve
we're trying to solve problems about the
fact that the thing doesn't make sense
in short distances and of course all
these things are supposed to make sense
at long distances because they're good
effective field theories we don't like
unless we're doing Ultra short distance
physics it has you know everything
should just make sense in some
reasonable way and but I learned what I
was learning about Loop quantum gravity
that's nowhere in sight right because
they're quite and like there's so many
lessons I didn't learn that were just
basic lessons about you know how should
theories be organized that were never in
the quantum gravity Playbook at least
when I was learning it and so yeah what
I learned doing string theory was like I
really learned effective field Theory I
learned when is there a problem that I
actually have to worry about starting to
do and what I mostly learned is that
this is very it's very small no and you
can do a lot of really really exciting
and cool stuff that's I would call
fundamental but without ever talking
about I've looked at your career and to
the best of my understanding your
careers is a stool with three basic legs
one of which is cosmology where you're
going to get data from all the great new
instruments that we're putting towards
the heavens uh second thing is effective
Theory so that you're going to reduce
everything to something which uh you
know at some particular scale is you
know very cleanly defined and you can
work with it
um and then the other thing is uh some
amount of particle theory where you're
going to hope to use the cosmological
through the effective Theory to
elucidate the nature of the fundamental
Fields as waves can Collision yeah so
that's I see your particular Gambit and
I'm 100 supportive of it you did refer
to yourself as a young person you're
over 40 if I'm not mistake unfortunately
okay so you're not a young person I
think I just crossed the threshold by
academic standards no no but you know
Iraq's old thing about a physicist the
past 30th year this is elongated in part
because of the fact that we deviated
from scientific Norms we don't have 25
year olds and 30 year olds who are
running the field the way I think of is
normal I think there are way too many
people in the field to be honest when
you're asking what would you do and I
feel that of those people they're not
properly arrayed up across first well
they're not for meonic there are plenty
of people who like Brian Green feels no
need to query Peter white who's putting
forward a twister Theory based on the
group su-4 and its inclusion of su3
cross U1 uh as a subgroup
um in twister space with a wick
continuation to su2 process YouTube
where one of the two halves gives the
weak force and therefore it gives you an
idea of va symmetry
you have to read your colleagues stuff
whether you like it or not
to be a good colleague you don't have to
read all of it but when you when you
can't put in 45 minutes then there was a
piece of French that was between 45 and
minutes that I didn't say on air
um and you say I'm too busy and then we
catch you playing ping pong in the
lounge or you're going to drinking or
you're writing a Blog about nothing in
particular it's completely disingenuous
now another example of this is gear at
least Garrett Lisi is a Snicker
dismantled okay uh no it doesn't work I
don't think it works it's got tons of
interesting good ideas in it and this
condescension against individual
research programs where somebody has a
really interesting idea and I think both
Peter white and Garrett are wrong and
it's not going to work
but I'll be God damned if I'm going to
stand back and say because I think I can
see why it's not going to work I'm going
to pretend that you have no ideas and
I'm going to slag you behind your back
as a colleague and I'm going to you know
dunk and drag on on Twitter this is
toxic behavior and so what I think is is
that we have very few idiosyncratic
programs that are able to even share a
stage there's no point of contact
where
I have an unusual bookmark in this book
yeah it's a dollar
this is a dollar signed by Sheldon glass
show where I want it uh in a 20-minute
discussion in his office and it took him
27 years to
27 I'm going to turn into an nft and
think bajillions
um it took him 27 years to acknowledge
that he'd lost the bet on whether G2
contained su3
I have no idea why that took 27 years I
like Shelley we have a good relationship
but the fact is you can't have people
saying oh I'm late to pick up my kids
that you know I have to go out to dinner
or whatever and never actually make eye
contact with the fact that they're not
giving real answers and by the way I
would love to actually talk physics
rather than about physics but what I'm
trying to say is that our meta problem
is is that with all the money floating
around nobody holds a conference saying
you know the last 40 years WTF with a
bunch of different theories like does
anybody else have an idea
and I can I can assure you I can go
you know on very large platforms and
talk about very concrete ideas I can try
to tell you why I believe that there are
three generations of matter why it's
chiral etc etc
and I promise you that the very weird
behavior is that people don't take it
seriously because what they're really
trying to do is not ask questions
they're really trying to say how do I
make this problem go away so I can get
back to the cargo cult science that I've
made a career around inside of a large
community that's what's dangerous see I
don't agree I don't agree with that I
mean I would say that a lot of people
aren't going to engage with I mean
the idea that what we need to do is find
the right way to unify the forces I
think it's just
as you said it's been unproductive and a
lot of people don't find that that's
what how they're like you know there are
weird hints from nature right like
cosmological constant is a weird hint
for nature sure and like we'd like to if
we like that unification or that
unification it wouldn't work but Daniel
if I ask you
what is your best guess as to why there
appear to be three generations of matter
would you say you have a guess
no I wouldn't I mean I would say there
are many people who have worked hard on
coming up with models all seem many seem
plausible like it could be
like I have no particular opinion and I
don't think that we're gonna find the
answer so if somebody came up to me who
could pass sort of a basic competency
test and so I think I know why they're
through generations of matter I would
find that fascinating Brian and I were
on the phone we were talking about this
issue and Brian said well what if I were
to tell you if something so exciting
that it has you know seven Sigma this
that which is to me would you race down
to San Diego I said sure
and I think he wasn't prepared for that
answer
there is something about the excitement
of believing things trying things and
caring about you what your colleagues
believe do you have any High conviction
beliefs about the extension of the
standard model
so I do have my high conviction belief
is that anything that extends the
standard model will look like a a
something that's an effective field
Theory so if I'm going to look for hints
experimental hints that are going to
tell me which way the world actually
works my strategy is going to be write
down everything I could imagine that
would look like a change to the
effective theory of this inner model and
go look for that okay and that's that is
what most
mostly but that avoids the question do
you personally have any High conviction
beliefs and I'll extend it do you think
we have anything wrong in the standard
model not just in terms of the
lagrangian and its consequences but in
terms of how we talk about it and do you
have any High conviction beliefs for
what extends it and what is likely to be
true that are really things like this I
believe can you say the phrases I
believe I believe that the uh that the
the universe is Lorenzen are in at Short
distances that the whatever unifies the
stand inner model is not breaking
Lawrence in variants
um
that if you observed if we were to
observe something cosmologically or
laboratory that would break your
conviction or it would cause you to
reveal excitingly you believe in
relativity
yes absolutely that is not very bold
okay
um but I mean by the way sorry most
things that are being proposed as
extensions to the standard model by
definition are well they might be wrong
most of them are wrong how do you know
Eric we haven't looked for actions they
can't all be correct they're not all
competitive some of them are music
because all I'm saying is this is to say
that the universe is manifestly uh
Lorenz and variant is an interesting
claim that could be falsified and by
falsification I think that would excite
you that wouldn't depress you that
wouldn't ruin your day it would totally
change how I think doesn't this I love
your puppy Point puppies are adorable
ice cream is delicious
but there are I mean I think I think
that's a case where people have
legitimately proposed ideas that
Breakers and they are interesting ideas
so uh you know someone who had an idea
that broke this principle that was
within the kind of traditional Community
but really broke away from it was uh
Peter harava with this you know
non-lorentz variant solutions to gravity
uh his proposal and again like it was an
interesting idea I didn't look at that
and go I understood what he's doing we
read those papers everyone's like you
read the paper you like but I also don't
think it's the way the world works and I
also that's not what I'm talking about
like if Zhao came out with something
maybe you look at it and then you say
okay that's pretty wild I don't buy it
but I understand but I think again the
difference between Penner who was
definitely deviating the weight from the
community was not that they're like he's
a card-carrying member of the community
is that he was able to communicate his
idea in a way that made sense to
everyone and but that but I guess what I
would say is like you're asking me to
take a definitive position about a
theory
absolutely you are you know and to be
fair to you because I'm not there's no
gotcha or Zinger here I see you as
mostly a cosmologist who is keeping the
door open to particle theory through the
conduit of effective Theory right and
that may not be fair because I've only
been studying yourself I understand well
I guess what I would say is that I no
effective field theory is life right
like it's like it's
how everything we organize it's just
it's all we see right I'm living here in
this like there's not like Newton's Laws
weren't wrong no no there's an effective
Theory relevant or if we were to talk
about biology right so we have the
stratification we have cytology the
study of cells below the meaning of
histology the study of tissues I mean
physiology above that and we have the
organization and anatomy And if you
stayed down at the level of saying you
know it would be absolutely responsible
for us to speculate into different
regimes because we understand that we
don't actually have information we've
learned the lesson of Ken Wilson very
well
that would be pretty disappointing if
you think about for example Wheel of
Fortune there are these one letter
solves where somebody actually guesses
the entire puzzle from a single letter
look up a guy named Rufus for example I
understand now my claim is is that the
the the dark side of the genius of Ken
Wilson and by the way Ken Wilson is a
good example like we just lost Jeff back
as a guitarist he was every professional
electric guitarist favorite guitarist
but he wasn't everybody's favorite
guitarist who didn't play guitar in a
certain sense Ken Wilson uh walks on
water within the competent community of
physics researchers but there's a dark
side also just the way Jeff Beck maybe
put too much emphasis on the whammy bar
of pushing everything into this realm
where it's denuded of much of its
meaning like if I were to say to you
that the Higgs field shows up in
effective Theory as a spin zero
fundamental scalar but I don't think
that that's its purpose I think it
actually belongs pixel and the way in
which it's disguised so that its spin
appears different than its naive spin
which is its function as a as a part of
a connection
uh that's something in which uh
effective theory is not going to
necessarily point to that because
effective Theory tends to show you uh
this picture that is often denuded of
higher level structures because we're
not too afraid to guess
no I the the idea is just that it
you could have as wild A variation of
the difference of the origin of two
theories as you like and if our limit my
observations to some energy scale by
colliders or whatever I can do that the
only way that I can tell them apart is
by the parameters of the long distance
Theory so now the parameters can be
really useful hints so in the 60s
Weinberg guests at asymptotic Freedom
which was that the idea that they're
like you know the theory is really made
up of you know quarks and things that
look like microscopic particles just
bouncing around even though they live
inside a proton he guessed at this
because of the specific relationships
between certain of the couplings of you
know Nuclear Physics because we couldn't
go and look inside of the proton at that
point in history so it's absolutely true
that through this lens you can discover
exactly as you're seeing you can within
this lens say ah there's a pattern here
and I can use the tools at my disposal
say the only way to get this pattern
points at some deeper deeper stretch
picture so that's exactly what we do so
for example why proton decay experiments
were so exciting because even though
they're low energy experiment we they
would tell us about physics at very high
energies because we only know a few ways
to create proton decay or this is why
people are really excited through the
masses because neutrino masses hint at
something going on at you know extremely
high energies that will never ever be
able to probe in the lab but if you
don't kind of on the other hand like if
I write down a theory that only changes
the gears of how the universe works on
some scale that I can never observe my
old hope is to see it through the
pattern
you're mislearning the lesson of the
baryon which is that the baryon isn't
encoded into the lagrangian the quarks
are but that uh you know I I don't even
know if we're talking a lot of sat
infrared slavery with uh new uh physics
conscience uh but you know the issue is
is that protons and neutrons are not
what is seen in the lagrangian you have
to actually unpack them
uh unpack the fundamental constituents
to get the observable constituents now
that lesson went over learned which is
what I'm concerned your community has
done
uh becomes inhibitory and everybody gets
innervated because nobody wants to be
the fool who didn't learn the lesson of
effective Theory and renormalization and
that's what what's concerning me is that
in general we have a group of people who
are incredibly worried about the union
card being respectable and when they're
heterodox they're heterodox in the most
mild and unhelpful way particularly if
you have a metastable state where small
perturbations don't work out very well
and so in all of these situations you
know when I try to engage you in terms
of if you want to actually talk physics
on a podcast
we always talk around physics we talk
about physics but we don't actually say
well what do you believe what do you
know what what are the high conviction
gets and I'll say something more
I think you're an extremely good
scientist I've read some of your stuff I
don't aspire
to be focused on good scientists because
I believe that we have a confusion that
great science is just good science
turned up to 11. and I think if you you
know I had this conversation with Jim
Watson his basic point was we were not
Watson Creek were not good scientists in
Jim's view he said Rosalind Franklin was
and the reason she didn't get the double
helix was not because it was stolen
which there are certainly issues but
because she refused to spend a day
decamped into the idea that the Maltese
crossed x-ray crystallography
represented a helix and so his point was
our search space is Tiny because we're
only looking for helical models and her
search space was enormous because she
correctly viewed that that particular
pattern was not sufficient to narrow it
down
but and you know someone watching is
just dispassionate but has some
knowledge of you and in the field I mean
you've ruled out you know just in words
today and not to mention previous
discussions we've had
um alternative theories to to you know
anything but your own you know personal
conviction which is that she so you've
ruled out EA you've ruled out and wool
from you've ruled out Loop quantum
gravity no I'm not saying ruled it out
like they shall be taken behind the
Woodshed no bro
I think we really need to study the
large exceptionally groups inside of the
tits foreign
I think that Peter White's Theory to
begin with su3 which is the one part of
this symmetry is that doesn't have
another name because U1 is also spin two
SO2 the circle same thing with su2 is
the three sphere spin three su3 is
unique in that it doesn't have another
name
and so he begins with that and he sticks
uh basically you three inside of su4 and
I think it's a great idea and I don't
want to be mischaracterized I am the
only person pushing forward gu
I am also pushing forward when I was
asked recently uh by The Institute for
arts and ideas they wanted to say well
tell us now about gu after you've done
all this service to our feelings like no
I don't want to do that I would rather
tell you about my competitors in
idiosyncratic permianic space it's you
guys who don't do that so please don't
put on me that I'm simply a proponent
that is always pushing my product and
selling from the stage far from I I
don't think it's selling from it but I
just from a pragmatic standpoint
Daniel's got a limited amount of
theoretical bandwidth my students do as
well
um
no I agree with you I agree with you
that that the to hear Sabine and say
well she doesn't have time to look at
your theory and Garrett's Theory and
wolfram's Theory she doesn't want to get
sucked in she doesn't want to but it
doesn't prove that it's right I mean
it's not it's not evidence that there's
no because believes the wrong impression
right and that's maybe not as collegial
as as it could be but there's a limited
no there's a limited amount so the
question is for working you know card
carries you call them union members yeah
I mean what is it about about what
you're doing that is most exciting and
most interesting to you and the reason
that keeps you getting up in the morning
and thinking about in the middle of the
night what what questions or what what
contributions are so interesting and
promising along the obviously promising
from the current research Direction
you're pursuing okay so I mean what have
I spent the past two years working on is
trying to understand the sitter space
now decision seems to be the universe we
live in it's also what do you mean by
that as in the expansion of the universe
right now is approximately it's
approximately just sitter okay so but
there's a big difference okay
um yes but
at the level of approximation that the
university seems to be a sitter we did
not understand how to calculate things
in the sitter and there are people who
claim that you know the center was
fundamentally unstable because of
various things that they couldn't
calculate and this proved that like you
know it's impossible to have a positive
cosmological constant for this reason or
the other and so I what I want to like
why do I use effective field Theory
because many of the calculations that
people were saying proved that this were
like they were instantly you could see
the mistake in the calculation so as you
say like yes effective field Theory you
can be have your blinders on to what
might be interesting but more often than
not in my career 100 it's like the way
you say hey that calculation of a
mistake in it and like well every time
it's a mistake it's like getting rid of
pseudo tensors it's a very good place to
catch errors absolutely so I don't I am
in no way saying like it's not
interesting to think about things that
yeah I'd be the first person excited
about a thing that doesn't look like it
lives an effective field Theory right
and so that would be awesome and I have
friends who you know explore you know
modifications to quantum mechanics and
maybe that means or things that look
like they violate the rules those are
extremely exciting and interesting
things a lot that people do seriously
consider but again if you don't start
from but if I have a theory that fits a
set of rules has to follow the structure
more often not you just do calculations
wrong right and it's like yeah you spend
five years doing calculation or in some
cases in this Inner Space like it was 30
years where people calculated things
over and over again and literally were
nothing there's tons of calculations and
we learned no lessons from it and though
part of the point of effective field
theory is that like it just organizes
what are interesting calculations what
the answer should look like and if
something violates effective field
Theory then at least you can go like but
what like waiter was the step that by
the way to the rules and if it did
nothing none of the steps violate the
rules then you've got a problem and so
what I would say for me like the what's
the ultimate goal of understanding
disorder space like it is getting back
to like what did the beginning of time
look like what is the space What are the
space of possible universes and like is
the multiversal well-defined thing does
it even make sense like these are
questions that are enormous and but we
can't answer like there are people who
want to jump to the like how do we
Define internal inflation and make up
rules for speculating and they make up
this and they make a pad and they say
well in my toy model with this Rule and
that rule it does this is like
we don't know enough to play those games
and I guess that would be my point of
view you're like in response to your
your comment about great scientists
um is that the challenge is ultimately
going to be like you know there are
moments in history that just call for
careful analysis of the laws we have
civilization in a certain sense
absolutely and the same with like
lagrangian mechanics hamiltonian
mechanics like there's a huge time
between Newton and she's just a question
the question is what time is it is the
time for a conservative Revolution is it
time for wildlife Revolution and I don't
think it's responsible for anyone to say
I know what time it is unless they have
a very good reason for saying that they
know what time it is so I think that to
your earlier point you want to let some
conservative people uh hug the shore and
say maybe we have a small error
um and you you may also I mean the the
dressed in Bear mass of the electron is
a perfect example of what seemed to be a
small area that cost two decades so at a
certain level
that's completely legitimate and what I
see you doing with effective field
theory is in some sense using it as a
substitute for experiment which is how
do we test whether our wild ideas
actually make a certain kind of sense
and so and I think it's very responsible
and part of the good science wrap that
I'm sticking you with is that you're
trying to do something where you can't
repeat the big bang you can't run an
experiment in the lab where everything
goes right an effective theory is a
great way of sorting some amount of
wheat from some amount of chaff provided
that you always keep in mind
that it also carries certain sorts of
distortions that bias us against bold
guesses because many of our structures
recur at various different strata of the
effective uh
stratification I I do not disagree with
that at all and I completely agree that
the you know even in our corner of
cosmology like I would not characterize
myself as a sprinklers but I have found
strength are useful because sometimes
even though I have not found anything
that cannot be expressed as effective
elderly like it does push us in a weird
direction there's like that idea came
out of left field and suitably
reinterpreted it was a really cool thing
to look this is what Nina said to me
about Ruby de schweiger Fields And The
Velo swansiger problem is he said that
it's very tricky to couple ravida
schwinger to external uh or to internal
degrees of freedom without having
superluminal problems String Theory
showed us a way to do that and so
whether or not you're a string Advocate
or not a string Advocate you at least
want to help yourself to the Bounty that
came from this Theory which is one of
the reasons why I'm absolutely not for
ending support for string theory but the
part of the problem is that this space
is so polluted by stupidity the world's
smartest people acting like jackasses is
that we're not having this conversation
fresh and new we're having this
conversation after not even wrong after
you know and part of the problem is is
that the field became not even Paulie
Paulie was a dick and he was famously he
was a witty dick he was a very high you
know very high standards I don't know
you know Switzerland they're very
precise over there but the fact of the
matter is is that he's a terrible person
for most people to emulate because it's
basically put down physics and so you
know what I really believe is you're
trying to do good science you're a new
generation I don't want you enmeshed in
some of these battles but I also don't
want you on the field of battle sort of
muddling the stuff and saying well there
are actually a lot of interesting things
we have certain things that we need to
get to in order to make sure that as
this generation before me exits the
stage they leave the situation like the
Cat in the Hat they've made a complete
mess of things and it's important that
they straighten things up before Mom
gets home yeah but I guess I would I
would I don't disagree there are a lot
of things that need to be cleaned up to
make it you know because but I think
that it comes in many forms and the
problem is that's
the the problem is that it's like you
can say oh it'd be good if you know
people came and fixed it is like a
handful of people who whose opinions
like just saying things carry anyway
most people it's the accumulation of a
life of work in the community that
eventually move the field so like an
example is like scattering amplitudes
like you know there's a like incredibly
great physicists who spent their entire
lives working on it and the way that
they like their results became part of
the rest of the community because of the
sheer weight of what they had been doing
it was not because it was like they get
a compelling talk or because like people
you know it was like really that it was
just like eventually they just solved so
many problems that people were like and
look at the great like this double copy
problem is really exciting absolutely
and the amplitude right so
but that's where I see that like I don't
like your point of view is like the
field is going to change when these
people have to exit the stage and like
and I think to be honest like I think a
lot of people younger them already see
these problems and it's just that like
they're like the way they're not they
don't have Ed whitton's name they don't
have ones but they see what you're
talking about and the way that that's
going to manifest itself is that in 20
years you're going to look back and say
that's what the many of these people
don't know
the hypercharged or the weak Isis spin
on the fundamental fields and I hate to
say this this way but I've dealt with
people who are quite a bit younger than
I am who are working in this area of
fundamental physics and I start to talk
to them about the field content of the
standard model and it's astounding what
they say they say things like oh yeah I
remember this in graduate school what
the f do you mean you're talking about
the fundamental constituents of Nature
and you can't remember the charge on uh
on the strange Quark you can't remember
whether it's you know or upper deck
there is some problem in which people
have actually departed physics
I think I think I I know exactly what
you're saying and I I know there are
phenomena like that so A version of that
which I think is a fair criticism is
that there was I don't know the names
but I've heard the story that if a um
someone who was up for a PhD there were
at their PHD defense and they were asked
what is the wavelength of visible light
and the person said one meter and the
the examer said do I look blurry to you
and like that's the kind of like you
should have real world intuition about
like in that case it's very obvious I
mean I would say like I can't I don't
memorize the periodic table I mean
periodic table is obviously important
but but it's not at some point 15 or 16
entries in a column vector
but again like you're asking like could
I if you woke me up in the middle of the
night could I reproduce every single
term in the in the standard model like
you know like I don't know that I could
I could get Mo I could get most of it I
can get most of the circle but it
doesn't matter to me in my in my
particular research because I want to
understand
you're not carrying around a copy
of the representation theory of sc3
quests you took crossed U1 on 15 or 16
dimensional complex space
thank you in a particle data look I
haven't done nothing
no spark quiz because I know exactly
where to look it up when I'm right now
he knows a club I know what most of the
terms are but if you had to get me like
what is the exact
for the same reason that memorizing a
poem is important because you can always
look it up but you're not going to be
able to have it uh if it's not cached
close to the prefrontal cortex you're
not going to be able to make use of it
in real time it's essential and I'm not
talking by the way about understanding
all the hadronic resonances or
um anything like that what I'm trying to
say is
the sense of oh yeah that's that stuff I
learned in graduate school I think to to
answer for danda he doesn't need what
Feynman said would apply I mean Feynman
would disagree with you and say what I
can't derive I don't understand he
didn't say what I can't memorize that on
Earth that's not a question of that it's
a question of for example let's forget
the exact you know weak hypercharge
assignments you could write down uh the
pseudo code of the standard model of
logic absolutely for sure so let's first
of all I'm talking about people who
can't do that oh I I understand what you
mean and I do agree that there's a
problem but at the same time like I do
like it's I think there's the like
should we do it the state should like
just as an intellectual Endeavor should
we remember should we pass down the
things that we've learned we should
definitely make sure the standard box
was saying that the younger people that
we're discussing
the consequence of not having this
reconciliation by the way of
understanding what quantum gravity did
to this field
this is that we have a number of people
who are not intact in their research
careers we're not in a position if the
answer came screaming across the field
of view they wouldn't necessarily
recognize but I I would say I would say
there's similarly a problem has nothing
to do with quantum gravity which was
that the response to all of this is that
particle physics has become divorced
from experiment and the problem is that
particle theorists don't know what it's
going to experiment and that is pushed
to the point that most young people that
I talk to who are particle
phenomenologists now were there people
who previously would have known the
standard model had a written down yeah
their feeling now is that like for them
to get a job and again is this actually
true or just what they perceive right
it's probably some of both but they feel
they have to have an experiment with
their name on it because otherwise
people say oh they're not in touch with
the real world and so now get you guys
more money that would be fantastic no
that's what we what I always say what we
need to do is to give my detractors my
uh people who are not critics but
actually more money because
what you're seeing is the Dynamics of
Hunger Game mentality inside of physics
and as a result of this we're not able
to behave constructively we're not able
to behave collegially when we we
separate ourselves so that certain
people on stage never encounter a Critic
I I was at Sai food in 2011 I believe
where Joe polchinski and Eva Silverstein
were talking about string theory in one
of the rooms and I went in and I
listened to Joe's version of the history
of string theory and I raised my hand I
said
they're like seven or eight things that
you just said that are not true
and I went through them and Joe to his
credit I said yep yep that's fair yeah
that's true that happened the way you
said it not the way I said it and I
watched Eva go White
she's just like she's gonna have to
speak and she had previously prepared
slides that duplicated many of the same
claims you know one of which for example
is that it wasn't that we never thought
about higher dimensional brains it was
called String Theory because there were
actually arguments that those higher
dimensional brains were guaranteed not
to be part of the theory and so once you
actually go through the reconciliation
where you say how let's talk about the
eight times we were wrong we said that
there were a finite number of theories
then there turned out to be a Continuum
where those things were extreme you know
I can go on and on and on in all of
those situations
by not forcing people to say yeah we
were wrong and and Joe palchinski is a
really good example I was pleased to see
him on your list not for string
theoretic issues or quantum gravity but
because of the effective Theory and he
was a good enough scientist to say you
know what you got me you're right he
also said to me something which you know
I want to be in the world he said you
Eric talk a lot about quantum gravity
and string theory and sometimes I don't
think string theory exists I said what
he said sometimes I just think we're
running subroutines for Ed and I thought
that was a profound moment that in
general one of the things that happened
which you may or may not know or feel or
understand is that when you would come
up with a new idea
in a previous generation everyone would
look around and say well what does Ed
say and it had to do with the fact that
people felt that Ed was channeling the
cosmos like Jimi Hendrix played the
guitar differently than everybody else
and so I was like what would Jimmy say
what would Jimmy do what would Jesus do
and he can't do that you'd have to
actually say well here's my opinion and
I may be wrong
um but the fact is we have to go back
and say why do we have this fictitious
history of the last 40 years and let's
also celebrate all the great stuff as
per your thread and also my arguments
about the fact that we actually put
Quantum field theory on a more solid
basis it's highly geometric and I
believe that the geometrization of
quantum field Theory and its divorce
from physics is one of the great
intellectual achievements of our time
and it deserves to be celebrated it's
just like wrong way Kerrigan you think
that you're going to end up as Lindbergh
but you end up going the wrong direction
all right well this has uh been the end
of round one uh
of this uh Thrilla in San Diego uh I
want to thank both of you guys and uh
hopefully we can do a round two but
actually I'm more interested in doing
something not on camera with you guys
and then just going through some really
fun physics
I learned so much from you uh uh both of
you guys and I I think yeah Dan Dan is
really a role model for many young kids
um I said it in the previous podcast you
know never have I been so glad to be a
guy enough to be a thief to steal you
away from other universities because I
think you really do exemplify the what
what a theorist or what a physicist
should be not a theorist an experimental
you you do both you're interested in
both and you're curious and then that
means so much to me and Eric of course
is is uh is is always so delightful
because you know I used to say the way
to put a physicist down and say well he
he or she knows the history of the field
really well but you you put your money
where your mouth is you're very devoted
to it I don't think it's for personal
attention I don't think it's for for uh
you know the satisfaction of fighting
the previous Wars as generals often do
but I I think it's it's for the sake of
Heaven in the sense that we are trying
to understand a universe that we came
into and we were like those fish that
don't really know what the water is and
you guys helped clarify for me simple
experimental cosmologist so now I want
you guys say one one thing okay yes yes
sir yes please I also think that people
often on the internet post these popcorn
memes like oh people are going to
conflict and the reason that we don't
get great fights on the internet that
are actually productive and help us
learn about the subject is because we
don't have a sense of Queensbury rules
and one of the things I just think is
terrific about Dan who I've never met
before
is that I had a high level of trust
um that he was focused on the physics
and not on scoring points dunking and
dragging I think people don't remember
what a Critic is I believe that Dan has
a certain sense my critic and I his but
the point is not to Blind him or you
know do small knuckle manipulations
the key point is if you want really good
conflict you have to establish
Queensbury Rules by people who are not
going to go for the jugular or bite off
an ear when they're in one of these
things and it's been an absolute
pleasure to come down and have this
conversation so touch gloves Dan
anything else you want to say no I would
say I I mean I I do I even that thread I
would say part of the role of a Critic
is not to be negative all the time I
mean the real value of the critic is by
being negative at times when they're
positive because real real meaning and
so I view that as a nobody's being
positive out there and let me be
positive and look forward to big things
that come from and another episode with
Eric coming out soon for now uh Barton
Keating joining you from University of
California San Diego we're blessed to
have brilliant uh colleagues like Dan
Dan Green and the friends of the show
like Eric Weinstein stay tuned more
great episodes coming up Susie Sheehy is
coming out this week and uh special
surprise guest coming next week so stay
tuned for now signing off